[Music]
hey guys welcome to ichi live I'm your
host Liana Galera and I am so thrilled
right now because the cast of Marvel's
cloak and dagger are joining me olivia
holt and aubrey joseph thank you guys so
much for stopping in right now this is
such a cool show because this is free
forms very first Marvel series you guys
are really kicking off a new genre for
the network we are going into episode 4
this week if you guys have not already
started watching the show binge it right
now
because it is so much fun um what is
this process just been like for you guys
seeing the show premiere you rapped in
November yeah yeah no it's been surreal
I mean we've been feeling so many
feelings and there's a lot so yeah it's
been it's a real experience reading just
a whirlwind you know we we actually
wrapped the pilot 2017 mission this
whole process has been a long time
for all the fans who are tuning in right
now send me your questions for Olivia
and Aubry and I will be passing them
along wow yeah you guys met almost a
year and a half ago then yeah can you
talk to me about your experience when
you guys first met and did you feel that
instantaneous chemistry that we see on
screen absolutely yeah no I mean the
audition process was it was fairly quick
because I think they really needed to
like dial in on like who they were gonna
cast so I know we both went in for
seperate auditions and then we had a
chemistry read and within that chemistry
read it just sort of it was magical you
know I mean we had that instant
chemistry and it's crazy because I feel
like it's so rare that you find somebody
that you like instantly connect with
they know nothing about them except
they're just like stoked to come in and
play the part and I know that we both
left that room feeling really confident
and what happened and then we booked the
part and we're here yeah Olivia what
fans have known and loved you from all
of your past projects but Aubry this is
really the first
time that fans are really getting to
know you and you're being thrusted to
such a high profile show what does it
been like for you I mean it's it's a
whirlwind to say the least but I'm glad
that I have someone like Liv you know
she um it was it was hard for me at
first just to you know get used to all
of all of you know the press and things
like that but Liv has just been there
you know kind of helping me and guided
me really just leading by example so
just just very happy to be here and
happy to be a part of a show like this
yeah well you guys have been live
tweeting all the episodes which I know
the fans really appreciate what has been
like a common question or something that
fans are talking to you about when are
you guys going to finally meet yeah I
know it takes it takes tandy and tire in
a minute to actually like have a moment
where they hash it out and really like
figure out what the situation is in
their lives I mean not just you know as
these new found superheroes but I think
also just like what's you know happening
in their lives as teenagers and I think
they really connect over that and that's
what makes their relationship so unique
and special and yeah and this week's and
in our fourth episode is the episode
it's it's great know it's the first time
that we actually see them hash it out
together or anything we'll start to see
them more and more and more so you
promise yeah well there's already a
little sneak peek from this week's
episode that is already out there and we
are seeing you to finally talk about
things and you talk about in the fact
that you know your character sees
people's hopes and your character sees
people's fears when you finally discover
that when you're reading the script do
you like this makes so much sense now
well the third episode for us was really
trippy thank you and I think it was for
everybody else too everybody was like
what's going on what's happening but I
think it's the perfect segue into this
fourth episode you know talking about a
lot of different situations and themes
because their show has so many layers to
it so I think once we sort of figure out
each other's powers and like how we can
cope with them and what we can do with
them I think that's when things start
making a little more sense yeah
it's just that way for them to keep
getting close to their answers right so
like live walking through my fears and
me well my hopes and me walking through
her fears this really kind of gives them
some answers but they really get their
answers when they finally meet yeah yeah
it's it's a very important episode and
it's one of my favorites I like the fact
that this show is a little bit more of a
slow burn you're really making fans like
wait on pins and needles to even
discover not only what their dynamic is
going to be like but also the full
extent of their powers
are we gonna continue to see their
powers evolve over this season and kind
of get control of absolutely yeah no I
think it's really important for the
audience to understand them not just as
you know this superhero duo but also as
individuals right I think that's what's
gonna make the audience actually
appreciate and respect what they're
going through so so yeah everything will
evolve I think not just the powers but
also the things that are happening in
their life like I think the answers will
start sort of like I'm unveiling
themselves a little bit more season
happens let's talk about your dagger the
first time in link you held it up I'm
like that's a cool dagger were there
multiple different options that props
showed you or were they like this is the
one that it's gonna be you know actually
before we started before we actually
started shooting I got a call from our
production team saying hey you know
we're gonna send you a dagger this is
dangerous but it's not obviously it's
you know it's it's plastic-like and they
just wanted to see how it would look and
fit in my hand yeah so that was a pretty
gnarly experience I like went to my you
know post office and picked up a package
and opened it and there was a dagger
inside of it pretty insane but yeah I
think you know as the season progresses
the dagger starts to change and becomes
more powerful as she like starts to
really understand her powers and what
she can do with them and and how she can
control the dagger so there are
different they're like a couple
different sizes on the daggers and you
know the way they are special effects
team is pretty and like insanely
talented
we you know a lot of a lot of props to
them for for making it so realistic yeah
well in Aubrey the concept of the cloak
at this point is kind of more of like a
mental cloak as well when how long are
fans gonna have to wait until we get to
actually see you full cloak out well I
mean that's that's the part of the show
that I love about it just that you know
you don't start the show and see these
two established superheroes that know
exactly how to use their powers and so I
think I think people are gonna enjoy the
journey of you know you know me finding
the cloak or the cloak finding me but
right now it's really his teleportation
is really off of what he's feeling or or
what he's thinking and so that's why you
keep seeing him end up everywhere like
all over the place so yeah I think we
should definitely just wait on it it's
coming people always talk about like
which powers you wish you could have in
real life and I thought teleportation
would be so cool but then I see
everywhere your character ends up we're
starting to get some great questions in
from Facebook and from YouTube ooh
Edward from facebook wants to know who
is your favorite Marvel superhero which
also how cool is that you guys are in
the Marvel Universe I know right no
we're pretty and it's hard to because
like we grew up going you know all the
Marvel to me this is like this is a hard
line but I mean I'd probably I probably
say Iron Man I've just been a massive og
man yeah for years and years but I'm
really excited to meet Captain Marvel so
yeah I would say Logan
Wolverine definitely but I'm just you
know of course really hype about
T'Challa and black panther of course so
Nikki on YouTube wants to know what has
been your favorite episode so far I'd
say I'd say our first episode is really
strong um I think it is a really great
representation of you know who our
characters are and the journey that
they're about to embark and we're you
know really lucky that we got to work
with Gina president right would who
directed our first episode
I mean I've worshipped her films since
day one so I'm very lucky to and
grateful to be able to work with her
but I also think we you know we're
really excited about for the fourth
episode is something that we're really
moving aboard everybody to sing they're
definitely four yeah speaking of the
pilot
I love the minimis they got to play your
younger selves Olivia your little girl
looks exactly what I was what I actually
googled unlike Olivia if I had one that
would I mean I
Rachel the girl who played the younger
version of Tandy she I would like show
her pictures of me when I was a kid and
they were identical like saying the
casting was like genius and perfect so
spot-on one also I love your younger
counterpart he has an acting range that
is a CEO is the tightest yeah he's gonna
go very far we're still getting in some
more fan questions keep sending them in
Andrea on Facebook says hello what do
you think was the greatest obstacle
getting into your characters I mean I'd
say for me just in my daily life I mean
I was Aubree like I'm more of an
extrovert
and Tyrone is definitely more of an
introvert definitely more closed off and
definitely has a guard up so that was
that was kind of hard for me playing a
shy character at first but you know I
fell in love with the character Tyrone
and I'm just really honored that I got
to play him yeah yeah no I think I'd say
for me you know I've I've grown up on
sitcom so this is definitely a whole new
transition for me going into a more
dramatic series we have a lot of fun of
heavy material on this show towards the
end of the season I think both of us
were like very emotionally and even
physically exhausted so I think just
transferring my headspace into something
that was a little heavier and and you
know talking about things that are
actually like current and happening in
this day and age was something that I
was very excited about but also can be
very challenging you know and doing it
in a tasteful way but also not
glamourizing it in any sort of way so I
mean there was a few challenges I think
within that realm but they were all good
challenges you know I think challenges
that sort of helped us grow and and and
not just you know that are gonna end
have to us as actors and help us evolve
as actors but I think that's gonna
impact the audience and that was
ultimately our goal so a little bit of a
challenge but I think you know hopefully
we're hitting the ground running with
that one well speaking of challenges I'm
curious to know what has the stunt work
been like for you guys on this year well
definitely Gina made it a point when we
first started shooting that she wanted
to do a lot of our own stunts and I feel
like we just kind of took that do the
rest of the season Wow we had a great
stunt stunt double team of course with
Brandon Shaw and and Antoine Lamar on my
end but um you know we really tried to
go out there and do our own stunts and I
feel like it just made the whole
superhero experience you know real yeah
it did it was interesting because when
we would I mean obviously like some of
the things that we did were a little a
little aggressive so I mean you know we
did them obviously a great stunt team
who sort of like helped us do it and you
know a safe space but yeah but I mean as
far as like the physicality when it was
it was really intense and I mean we had
some days where we were like okay maybe
we just need to like lay low by the way
we got so many steps in like I have
never ran so much in my life I'm
actually true yeah I mean the suicides
your character had to do it you guys are
this constant always running somewhere
yeah yeah my favorite is running away
from everything so wait literally so
what is your what is your treat yourself
thing that you used to have on set like
if you had a particularly grueling day
what was your little reward there was
definitely always some sprite waiting
for me in my tree
why did you bring us food then we're
good we were in New Orleans so we were
set yeah how did you not get like
immensely overweight with all those
beignets because
when also Oh Joe on Facebook says did
you guys research the characters from
the books and how much of that did you
bring to the show and he also adds he's
a big fan of the show thanks Joe
yeah we we we dived into the comics a
lot when we first started just to sort
of understand the tone and the
characters and their journey and even
though we've sort of you know taking a
different twist on the origin story it
was really important for us to get to
know cloak-and-dagger as as the team
that they are in the comics so even
though our show is a little bit
different I feel like I feel like
there's still sort of that same tone and
level of you know compassion and trust
that they have for each other in the
comics and our hair makeup trailer
actually had the the ladies of the hair
makeup tailor postured poke and dagger
comics all over the hair and makeup also
which is yeah it was awesome I mean it's
sort of like gave us like a great vibe
just to start the day but then we could
also like have a fun little light ray
before we started shooting yeah fans
whenever they're watching a TV show
whenever someone has great on-screen
chemistry they're automatically like oh
my gosh I shipped those two characters
together yeah and I'm sure that's
already happening we heard characters
what do you want to say to the fans out
there about the dynamic between the two
of them moving forward well to me right
now it's just more about the
companionship that and you know these
two have been connected by fate
undeniably so it's it's just about them
figuring each other out and you know
kind of becoming friends before anything
else happened so yeah yeah yeah I think
the beauty of their relationship is
definitely the friendship at first so
yeah we've got time for a couple more
questions from the fans
ooh Pam on Facebook great question she
says which Marvel series would you like
to make a cameo in we always talk about
this I mean every single one of them you
know we always say that we feel like
Runaways would make more sense you know
I mean they also did a crossover in the
comics as well so and we're all you know
around the same age yeah and he's just
sort of running around and figuring yeah
so I feel like Runaways would make more
sense okay and we're also friends with
the cast and we love them and just are
dying to work together that would be so
cool yeah that would be although we
agree
we're like last fam question is also
from Brendon on Facebook oh wait no do
we already have one from Oh welcome
Brendon this is brand new um will we see
you well we see somewhat of who the main
villains will be this season or will
that be more something for season two I
think for this first season we're
obviously focusing a lot on Tandy and
Tyrone yeah lationship and and and and
their path and their journey and I think
you know you'll start to see a couple
familiar faces from the comic is such as
you know like Bridget O'Reilly and
father Dell God Father Delgado I think
those are like two main people from the
comics so I think you know we'll sort of
see that unveil as the season goes on
but I think you have to continue
watching to find out I'm going to look
ahead right now for our last question
together because I'm so excited episode
4 airs tomorrow but I want to look ahead
to episode 10 your finale can you give
us a cheese for what that episode is
gonna be like or what your reaction was
when you read that final script hmm well
first absolutely no teasers but I mean
definitely when I read the episode I was
just floored I was like yeah this is
this is the finale it's it definitely is
a huge episode and I think sets the tone
for where they go next yeah it's it's
overwhelming and on all the right ways
like everything that you can want and
need and I think you know as every
single episode happens and you watch it
you'll you'll understand when episode 10
comes out why everything happened and
and hopefully you know it's a good segue
into another season figures car and
there's mad cross well Olivia are we
thank you so much for sitting down with
me today I really appreciate it thank
you to all the fans for sending in your
questions be sure to check out Marvel's
cloak and dagger every Thursday at 8
p.m. on freeform and we'll see you next
time guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]